>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Jane Sanchez: Good
morning, everyone.
Good morning, Library
of Congress colleagues
and our very special guest.
My name is Jane Sanchez
and I'm told
that I'm the 25th Law
Librarian of Congress.
It is my honor to
welcome you today
to the Law Library's annual
celebration of Law Day.
This year's Law Day
program is entitled "Justice
through the Perspective
of an Eye-Witness Artist".
And we're doing this in
conjunction with the opening
of the Library of Congress'
exhibit, "Drawing Justice:
The Art of Courtroom
Illustrations.
Today's program is sponsored
by the Law Library of Congress
and the Library of Congress
Prints and Photographs Division.
We are honored today to
bring together a panel
of three artists to talk about
their work, Marilyn Church,
Pat Lopez, and Bill Robles.
To begin, just a few
words about Law Day.
It was first proposed
by the American Bar Association
President Charles S. Rhyne
in 1957.
Mr. Rhyne envisioned
Law Day as a way
to celebrate America's
legal system.
In 1958, President Eisenhower
issued the first presidential
proclamation designating
Thursday,
May 1, 1958 as Law Day.
And I quote, "It was to be
a day of national dedication
to the principle of
government under laws."
In 1961, Congress passed Public
Law 8720, establishing May 1
as Law Day USA in perpetuity.
Since 1961, presidents have
issued annual proclamations
calling on all Americans to
celebrate Law Day and our system
of government and laws.
Before our panel
begins this morning,
I have a couple housekeeping
announcements.
Can you switch off
your mobile phones,
if you can, to silent mode?
And please note that this
program is being videotaped
and later will be available
on the library's website.
After today's program,
we invite everyone
to visit the exhibition,
Drawing Justice:
The Art of Courtroom
Illustration.
The exhibit is in this building
on the second floor
south gallery.
Before we get started, a
couple thanks are in order.
To Mr. Tom Girardi for making
this exhibition possible,
to Thomson Reuters
for their generosity
in supporting today's
program, to the Library
of Congress Prints and
Photographs Division,
our cosponsor, and to the
friends of the Law Library
of Congress, thanks
to all of you
for your many contributions
making this event possible.
And now, I would like to
introduce Sara W. Duke,
Curator of Popular and Applied
Graphic Art in the Library
of Congress Prints and
Photographs Division.
Sara came to the
library as a wee baby
in 1991 as a junior fellow.
As a curator, she
acquires cartoon art,
documentary drawings,
and ephemera.
Sara will introduce
today's panel
and she will moderate our
panel discussion today.
Sara?
[ Applause ]
>> Sara Duke: Thank you, Jane,
and thanks to everyone else
who made this day possible.
It's very exciting to have
98 courtroom illustrations
on the walls of the
Library of Congress.
I have three artists
that I've brought
in for this discussion today.
We'll start with Marilyn Church.
She earned a BFA from Pratt
Institute in Brooklyn, New York
and attended graduate school
in the University of Virginia.
She returned to New
York intent on a career
in fashion illustration, but
found herself falling in love
with the best dramas in town,
the ones that happened
in the courtroom.
In 2009, the Library of
Congress acquired her archive,
a generous gift of over 4000
drawings from her family
which includes such trials of
famous defendants as John Gotti,
Martha Stewart and
Robert Chambers
and the late blind militant
leader, Omar Abdel-Rahman.
Second, and I'm doing this
in alphabetical order,
is Pat Lopez.
Pat began her career with a
lengthy Silkwood v. Kerr-McGee
in 1979, almost immediately
after graduating
from the Southwestern of
Oklahoma State University,
where she studied art
education and commercial art.
Known for her distinctive
representational style,
she has traveled over-- all
over the United States to cover
such well-known travels--
trials as Terry Nichols
and Timothy McVeigh in Oklahoma
City before their trials got
separated, the Waco
Branch Davidian co-trials
in San Antonio, Texas,
and Citadel v. Faulkner
in Charleston, South Carolina.
And you can see all of
those drawings upstairs
after this discussion.
The library acquired a small
archive of Ms. Lopez' work
through a combination
gift purchase.
Finally, last but not least,
Bill Robles is a Los Angeles
based courtroom artist
who earned his BA from the
Art Center College of Design.
After working as an
advertising illustrator,
CBS Evening News hired him
to cover the 1971 trial
of Charles Manson
and his family.
What a way to begin
a career [laughter].
Walter Cronkite led
off the Evening News
with his drawing the
day Manson attempted
to stab the judge with a pencil.
And you can see both Mr.
Robles' drawing as well
as Cronkite's Evening
News broadcast upstairs
in the exhibition.
He has worked in
courtrooms ever since,
covering the Los Angeles
trials of O.J. Simpson,
Michael Jackson, and
litigator, Thomas Girardi,
but traveling further
afield is needed.
The library acquired a selection
of Robles' work as part
of the Thomas v.
Girardi collection
of courtroom illustration
drawings.
And with that, ladies
and gentlemen,
I'd like to invite you
to come up to the stage
so we can begin our discussion.
How many of you have
been in a courtroom
and seen an illustrator at work?
>> Bill Robles: Oh, really.
>> Sara Duke: OK,
so a few of you.
I guess since the
majority of the people
in this room haven't
seen you at work,
why don't you give
the audience a sense
of about how you get hired and
what it takes to get yourself
into the courtroom
to draw a trial.
>> Marilyn Church:
Shall I start?
>> Bill Robles: Ladies first.
>> Pat Lopez: Please,
please go first.
>> Marilyn Church:
Ladies first [laughs].
It's so difficult from getting
in the door sometimes
a long waiting line
for a high-profile trial, and
you're lugging heavy supplies.
And when you do get in, you're
often fighting for a seat
with the reporters who
also want a front-row seat,
they want to hear.
You want to see another artist.
Everybody wants the
best viewpoint.
And we draw with our supplies on
our laps, a pad and it's crowded
with other artists, and
you're balancing every thing,
sometimes water, sometimes
trying not to make noise,
trying to pull out your
binoculars to see when you're
in a very dark space and the
defendant may be backlit.
It's all kinds of obstructions
from morning till you finish.
And sometimes, you have a
very short time to finish,
like sometimes less than an hour
or 20 minutes in an arraignment.
So, I could go on and on
about how difficult it is,
but I'll leave some for you.
>> Pat Lopez: OK.
Well, as Marilyn said, the
same experience with me.
We're always looking for the
best seat in the courtroom
but so is everyone else,
especially the attorneys.
And sometimes I have to bargain
with them to get the best seat,
which means, oh, I'll put a
little more hair on your head
until you give me
that seat [laughter].
But not only that, it
was because we were
in the best seat, we were the
first to see forensic evidence,
the first to see all the
drama that would happen.
In fact, we had to
have-- we had to sort of--
I did, anyway, had to
build my intuitive sense
or radar of the courtroom.
If something were
going to happen,
you could almost feel
it before it happened.
In other words, if I were here
drawing what the goings-on
in the well of the court
and a family member,
as happened in the Oklahoma
City bombing case that I did,
a family member stood up and
started screaming or crying
or whatever, that
would be the story.
Then I had to grab
a new sheet of paper
and instantly start drawing it.
So, not only fighting for
our seat, but keeping it
by getting the story
when it happened.
Bill?
>> Bill Robles: Again,
seating is everything.
>> Pat Lopez: Yeah.
>> Bill Robles: Getting there--
It depends, there are so
many high-profile trials
in Los Angeles that you
have to get there early.
And it's a call-in thing.
The TV station just phoned and
they get the name on a list.
And artists kind of have a
priority, but it's no guarantee
that you're going to get in.
>> Marilyn Church: Right.
>> Bill Robles: Sometimes
the-- If there are two artists,
there's a flip of a coin
and whoever gets it goes in.
But in most high-profile trials,
they only allow one artist.
So, the other artist and
myself usually flip a coin
and whoever wins
goes in the first day
and then we alternate days,
so that kind of works out.
But I remember during
the Menendez--
Remember the Menendez
Brothers trial?
The judge did not like the media
and he did not allow cameras,
but he let the artists
in, but he put the artists
in the corner of the courtroom.
So it was really very difficult.
That's where your drawing
skills have to play in.
And like you said, arraignment
sometimes 10 minutes, they're in
and they're out, and boy, you've
got to capture it like that.
>> Marilyn Church: And you see
mostly the back of their heads.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church: You pray
that they'll turn sideways
and say something to--
>> Bill Robles: We love the
side views and we love beards
and mustaches, big hair.
>> Marilyn Church: Yes.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Bill Robles: It makes it
a lot easier, doesn't it?
>> Marilyn Church: Right.
>> Pat Lopez: It does.
Right. I think the shortest
amount of time, I don't know,
when you said short,
I mean short.
I remember during the Jasper
dragging death, this was a trial
in Jasper, Texas,
a very small town,
and the courtroom was probably
a century old, beautiful.
I had to stop myself
from engaging
in so much time drawing all
the beautiful carved woodwork
and the old fans.
They even had brass batons
at the bottom of the--
but I had to sit next to it
because it was the best seat.
Anyway, during that trial, Dan--
At that time, I was working
for CBS, I was a contractor
for whoever called
first, so freelancer.
They had told me that
Dan was on the front lawn
with his entire crew, they
were doing a live shot,
it was at the end of the trial.
And yet, I had work to do.
The trial wasn't over but
everybody left to go see the--
you know, all the
goings-on on the lawn.
I was one of the few people
left in the courtroom and I knew
that I was waiting for the most
important piece of the trial,
the chain that these
people had had hooked
on to the victim's
feet, James Byrd
and they drug him to his death.
Well, this chain
hadn't showed up
yet in the courtroom
as evidence.
I waited and waited.
And finally, they brought it
out when the courtroom
was near empty.
But they forgot, I was
still there, so I--
they brought the chain out.
He held it up and held
it for maybe two minutes.
I got it. The drawing
is downstairs.
>> Marilyn Church: Good.
>> Sara Duke: So, you've all
had long careers as artists.
How did your technique
evolve over time?
Did you change the
materials you used?
Did you start out
looking like somebody else
and developed your
own distinctive style?
Or did you always have
your distinctive style?
>> Bill Robles: There
was really nobody else.
I mean, it was kind of
started way back just part
of the Manson trial.
This is almost-- Well,
it's 46 years ago.
This August will be 47 years.
But, I had never set foot
in a courtroom in my life.
I was a fairly successful
illustrator for 10 years
and then the murders came
up and one of my classmates
from Arts Center
became the art director
at the CBS station
in Los Angeles.
So, I always had an interest
in news as a kid, newsreels.
So I approached them
as to who to see
at CBS, show them my work.
And they liked me and they hired
me as their freelance artist.
And I've been freelance for
all those thankful times, but--
so that's all that came about.
Right place, right time with
the right qualifications, so--
And, you know, that started
the whole career, you know?
>> Marilyn Church: And I
was a fashion illustrator
when an attorney friend of mine
told me about this trial going
on in the Queens courtroom.
And right away, it just sounded
such an exciting thing to do.
And one of the things
about doing fashion illustration
is you have to draw very fast
and you're drawing a lot
of-- the whole figure,
so you have that background
which was good to go
into the courtroom with.
And I think, you know,
my courtroom career spanned
almost 50 years or 45.
So, naturally, you grow
as an artist, you know?
I-- There's some very early
drawings of me downstairs.
There's many techniques
down there.
There's watercolor,
there's black and white pen.
And gradually, over the years,
also the difficulty of drawing
in court makes you perfect what
you bring to court, what's going
to be quiet, fast,
efficient, not going to smear,
you have to be ready at a
moment's notice to wipe out part
of your drawing and start over
or just pack up and get out.
They change courtrooms
mid-trial.
Suddenly, you have to go
somewhere else, or just flying
out to get your work
videotaped outside.
You have to be mobile.
So, all of that affects the
technique that you end up using.
And I think also, the artist
that you sit with, you know,
most of the art that
I did over the years,
we were on high-profile trials,
there could be seven
artists there.
There wasn't one or two artists.
>> Bill Robles: Oh, I know that.
>> Marilyn Church:
There were many.
And so, there was a lot of
sharing, I think, of ideas,
looking at other artists
work, seeing what they use,
if it was easier and
adopting from each other.
>> Pat Lopez: Mm-hmm.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: As a matter
of fact, I agree with you,
always looking at
other artists work.
When I had great artist
in the court with me like,
Bill and one time with Marilyn,
I was-- I could feel it.
It helped my work to be better
because they were there.
The level was so high.
But I began because I
watched artists on television.
The one artist that really
impressed me was Howard Brodie.
And he was a sketch artist who
used mostly black and white ink,
but he was-- or I think pencil.
Anyway, I saw his work and
was just so impressed with it.
And I knew that I could do it,
somehow I knew I could do that.
I just graduated from
college, I went--
I was at my mother's house
when I saw Howard Brodie's
work on television.
So I took a chance and
picked up the phone
and called the local
CBS station and I said,
"Do you need an artist?"
And it just so happened
that the man who picked
up the other phone was in
Oklahoma City at the time
for some other reason.
It was Ed-- Let's see,
Ed-- not Ed Turner.
Ted-- Ed Turner, yes Ed-- Ted
was the other guy, Ed Turner
and he was at CNN at
the time and he said,
"Can you draw people?"
And I said, "Yeah."
Well he used an expletive
that I won't repeat here,
but I said, "Yes, sir, I can."
"Get down here right now."
So I did. He had me demonstrate
by drawing the anchor
who was giving the noon
news live in the studio.
I was scared to death.
So I did the drawing
and he said,
"You walked in off the street?"
So, I was hired.
My first drawing, I had
to do the following Monday
in the Denver circuit court
because Oklahoma was
impeaching its governor.
That's how I began.
It was with Howard
Brodie guiding me in.
His son is back there,
he looks just like him.
I just want to cry.
But the way-- The
reason I'm here is
because his father looked at
my artwork, I asked him to look
at it and tell me, am
I doing anything wrong?
Is this-- And he looked at
it long and hard and said,
"Kid, you've got talent.
You can do this but you have
to work at it every day.
And then you could
be one of the best."
So, here I am.
Thank you, Howard
[ Applause ]
>> Sara Duke: So, all of
you have an art background.
Bill mentioned a love of
journalism, newsreels.
But you're journalists
as well as artist.
And Pat mentioned the
need to train her eye.
So how did you train yourselves
to pay attention to the news,
to pay attention to
elements of the courtroom,
because you decide
for television viewers what's
important in any event?
>> Bill Robles: The
main thing you've got
to get the person that's
involved in the trial,
whether it's an arraignment
or a trial going on,
but number one, you've
got to get in.
I try to compose the
situation, so it's--
graphically tells a tale without
a lot of superficial stuff.
So, mine is more of
a vignette style.
But, you know, the media
wants it fast, fast, fast.
I remember years ago,
I was doing something
and the reporter literally
took an unfinished drawing
out of my hand and says, "Well,
listen, we need it on the air."
You know, it's so exaggerated
because it wasn't that critical.
But he took the drawing
without being finished, so.
>> Marilyn Church: I
feel that happens almost
with every drawing, it goes on
before I consider it finished.
>> Bill Robles: Especially
today, right?
>> Marilyn Church:
Yeah, out of your hands.
Yeah, but-- Wait a
minute, what was your--
oh, your question was--
>> Sara Duke: How did
you train yourself to--
>> Marilyn Church: The--
It's really important
that you know the story,
and what's important
in the courtroom.
You know, the most-- the
witness they're waiting for.
And so, you do try to arm
yourself with that information
and talk to the reporter.
Hopefully, the reporter is
sitting next to you and can kind
of signal, "You know, the next
one that's coming is the one I
want," but many times,
you're isolated.
And you have to know.
So you really have
to be following the same time
what's going on in the story,
and planning, you know,
leaving room in your drawing
or being able to adapt it
and completely change it
or start all over very quickly
when that news breaking--
I mean, the thing that's going
to be the top of the story.
And I think you also want
your drawing to make sense,
because it's on the
television a very short time,
so viewers should be able to
look at it quickly and able
to absorb the story
of what's going on.
So that's a challenge too,
I think, to make it clear.
>> Pat Lopez: I think she's
correct and I will add,
it's not-- the average time
I was told by a producer
in very sharp tones one day,
the average time that it--
because I wanted to complete
a drawing and she wanted
to have it right then, that she
said, "They just see it for 13
to 20 seconds," I'm sorry,
but that's how she said it.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: And I thought,
well, it doesn't matter.
It tells a story and it has
to have all of the story
in the picture, I can't
just put part of it.
So I totally agree.
It was oftentimes a trial
to try and get everything
in that you needed to get
in, in the time that you had.
And I wanted to say
something else too.
In terms of having limited
time and knowing the story,
you have to know every part of
that story, every defendant,
every witness, every victim,
even the families
in the audience.
>> Marilyn Church: Right, yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: So that you
knew who was standing up
and shouting, or whatever
it is you needed to do.
There were-- I even made
a habit, and this is going
to sound strange,
but it helped me.
Sometimes, I would go to the
crime scene and that helped
to introduce a different
level of emotion for me,
the Jasper dragging
death was a good example.
I actually went to the actual
scene, so I could know--
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: -- what that was
and what the family endured
when they heard the story.
>> Sara Duke: So, Pat and Bill,
especially, but Marilyn too,
your trial drawings cover this
breadth of the United States.
So, how do you get hired and
how fast do you have to react
and how do you get from
place to place to cover?
>> Bill Robles: What do you
mean from place to place?
>> Sara Duke: Like if you're
not in your home city.
>> Bill Robles: Right.
>> Sara Duke: Who
pays for you to travel
and how do you get there and
how fast do you have to react?
Like, when do you find
out that you're traveling
to another city to
cover a trial?
>> Bill Robles: You know what,
when the Unabomber was arrested
in Helena, Montana,
you remember him?
CBS called me, "You got to
get down to the airport.
You're going to go
to Helena, Montana."
So I gathered the stuff
as quickly as I could,
got in the car, got-- went to
the airport, missed the flight.
And a radio reporter from Los
Angeles also missed the flight.
So, we flew to Spokane,
he rented a car,
and we drove all night
through the Rockies, snow,
and he would-- the reporter
would stop every hour
to make a phone call to call
in his story all
the way over there.
We got there at 7:00 in morning,
got to the hotel, showered
and shaved, and got to
court in time to see him.
But that was the only
time that happened.
Usually, I have advanced
time, but that was--
and with LA traffic, you
know, it's [laughter]--
>> Marilyn Church: We know.
Usually, you get a day's notice,
if you have to travel,
but not always.
There-- I have those
stories too,
where it was all
the last minute.
I remember the-- when
they caught Bernard Goetz,
who was the one who shot
the kids in the subway
that were trying to rob him.
>> Bill Robles: Oh, yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: And it
was going to be up in Maine
and there was no time to get
a regular flight and we went
by helicopter with reporters.
So, that was anything to get
there and get the drawing.
And again, an arraignment, went
all the way to Maine and it was
like over in 15 minutes.
But you have to have
a variety of drawings
and sometimes not just one.
And also after-- I wanted
to say after I was at the--
when I was first starting out,
almost my first trial
was the John Mitchell,
the attorney general
who was part
of the Nixon administration
on trial in New York.
And I really was new at it
and the other artists
were much more expensive--
much more experienced
[laughter],
and probably getting a lot
more money than me too.
So after I've been there
just a bout a month,
the New York Times
called me and asked me
to come in with my portfolio.
And I saw other artists there
too that had left samples.
Somehow, they gave
that assignment to me.
It's really hard to know
why, but I felt so fortunate
about it, but that's
how that happened.
>> Pat Lopez: In my
experience, as I was--
mostly my niece was
the heartland,
the middle of the nation,
although I did come
to New York once or twice
and I did work with Bill once
or twice or-- well, not in
California, but in Texas.
>> Bill Robles: In
Texas and Oklahoma City.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes,
Oklahoma City.
In fact, Oklahoma City, because
I lived in the heartland,
my family was there
also and many
of the trials somehow
affected my personal life.
To give you an example, the
Oklahoma City bombing happened,
I was at home in
Austin that morning.
I received a phone
call, turned on the TV.
I turned on the TV.
I could see the Murrah
building going up in flames.
My sister parked her car
in the Murrah parking lot
and worked a block away.
As I was dealing with that, CNN
said, "We have a private jet.
Get on it now."
So I got on it to
go to Oklahoma City.
We sat in an RV in
front of the building.
They're still searching
for people.
I was there within an hour.
I didn't know if my sister
was alive and had to wait
until they had someone to--
they thought they were going
to arrest someone
immediately, but they didn't.
So I just sat there
in that RV, waiting.
I didn't know until
later that evening
that my sister had survived,
but that was a very,
very difficult thing.
There were oftentimes
that I had to go to trials
that would affect someone I knew
because it was in
Oklahoma or Texas.
>> Jane Sanchez: After
you make your drawings,
I know there are sometimes
issues with controlling them.
I know you ended up
suing for the right
to prevent another agency
from selling your work.
So, how assiduously do you
have to guard your copyright
and your images once
you make them?
>> Marilyn Church:
Intimately [laughter].
It's true.
You know, sometimes when all
the cameras are outside lined
up to shoot your work,
there'll be some small station
that doesn't have a big
budget coming over, you know,
and shooting and sometimes, you
don't even know it's happening.
And sometimes, they
see my work on--
I saw several shows
on Oprah Winfrey,
I saw it on Saturday Night
Live, never got any compensation
for that and would put
in bills afterwards.
So sometimes it worked
and sometimes it didn't.
I mean, I don't want to
hire a legal defense and try
to get my fee, but
yeah, that happens.
You do-- You have
to be vigilant.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes,
unfortunately.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: I had
to be very vigilant.
I was in the middle of
working a very large case
when infringement happened
and it was critically
important that I stop it.
I was under contract
with another entity
and my work was being used.
I could have lost my career.
So that's how that--
all of that happened.
Not a happy thing,
copyright [laughs].
>> Marilyn Church: Right.
>> Bill Robles: It's-- I
remember one high-profile trial.
There were a media
frenzy as usual.
And it was Lindsay
Lohan, her appearance
at Airport courthouse.
It was like insane and
so many, many people.
Anyway, coming down the
stairs, I had a drawing of her
and I was going out to--
I do for multi-stations,
if you're lucky, you can get--
if you're the only
artist allowed,
you can do for everybody.
I'm coming down with a
drawing upside down heading
for the truck for them to shoot
and there was a photographer
that was running
alongside with me
with a camera trying to shoot.
And you have no control
over that.
>> Marilyn Church: Right.
>> Bill Robles: I
saw a drawing I did--
I think it was a major
trial, I happened to--
I was flipping to see channels
over the evening and came
across a Korean station with
my drawing on [laughter].
And they had never purchased it.
So I tracked them down and
they had to pay the fee.
So occasionally, you're lucky.
During the O.J. trial, I had
a jury drawing that appeared
in News Week, a double page.
A German newspaper ran it.
A friend of mine happened to
be married to a German girl
and she worked for German
media magazines in Los Angeles.
And she told me about it.
So, long story short,
I contacted them,
they ended up paying $3000.
And they were here.
And of course they wanted less,
but I stuck with my guns and--
Occasionally, you're luckier
like that but most of the time,
people steal stuff and you
have no control over it.
And now, they can literally
take drawings off the internet,
you know, and do what they want
with them, make prints and--
you know, so you're
really at their mercy.
>> Pat Lopez: That's true.
Even today, I can see my work
elsewhere that I don't know
where they received that.
>> Bill Robles: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: So, I do have a
copyright attorney I work with.
>> Bill Robles: You do?
>> Pat Lopez: Yes, I do.
>> Marilyn Church: That's good.
>> Pat Lopez: In fact,
he'll be here tonight
at the dinner [laughter].
>> Marilyn Church: OK.
>> Pat Lopez: I had
to thank him somehow.
>> Sara Duke: So, you all
have a distinctive style.
I feel like I've broken it down,
but I ask these three people
because they have what I would
call the California style,
the Midwest style, and the New
York style, which was also--
the New York style and the
Washington style aren't
that far part.
>> Marilyn Church: Are
not that far apart.
>> Sara Duke: Yeah, I think
they're both influenced
by each other.
So how did that evolve, that
each region of the country has--
>> Bill Robles: That's true.
>> Sara Duke: -- such
a distinctive style,
or you've never thought
about it before?
>> Marilyn Church: I really
think it had a lot to do
with who was sitting
in court with you--
>> Pat Lopez: Absolutely.
>> Marilyn Church: --
influencing each
other, I really do.
I think the drawings
talk to each other
and the artists absorb
the culture around them
and I think that's
a big part of it.
>> Pat Lopez: I think
she's right.
I think I will add that
in the Midwest, of course,
is way different than the East
Coast or even the West Coast
in terms of the community, the
people who are-- the viewers.
And I called my stuff mom and
pop drawings because if I was--
if I were to draw--
for instance, I did the
Kobe Bryant rape hearings,
it had to look like Kobe.
It had-- And it couldn't be
quick and it could-- I'm not--
these two are very, very
gifted in doing quick drawings
and they can make
great likenesses.
I can't do that, you know,
I have to do something
that's really,
really almost like a portrait.
And I think that the family
or the mom and pop idea came
from mostly my family.
My mother was my biggest critic.
And if it didn't look like
someone, she'd tell me.
So I tightened up my
style because of that
and learned how to
do that quickly.
But that's the only way I can
do it fast is to do something
that has a tighter image.
I can't do this expressive
stuff that--
the beautiful stuff that the
two of you do so quickly.
But I can do it.
If I do it tight, I
can do it quickly.
It took a while to do that,
but with my mother behind
me, I did it [laughter].
>> Bill Robles: It's very
difficult to get quality
when you're limited
by time, you know,
when things are done
[inaudible].
Sometimes, you hate
to let a drawing go
because it's not
perfect, you know?
But, you know, capturing
the likeness is key I think.
And everybody is going to know
if the person does not look
like the person depicted on TV.
The whole-- The public
is going to know it.
So that's one of the
big pressures, I think,
in trying to capture
the likeness.
You know, it's very important,
and very difficult,
very difficult.
Added pressure of
course, speaking of that,
it's a very difficult just
to do and we're all seasoned
so we know how to deal with
all the shortcuts and tricks
and so on, and experienced
and skilled.
But I've had artists that I
knew tried courtroom drawing
for another station and
they couldn't handle it.
One of them went out and threw
up because of the pressure.
So it's really a very
difficult grind and you have
to be dependable, you know,
television relies
on your deadline.
And, boy, that's
a lot of pressure.
But, you know, you deal with it.
I think you have to have
the mentality for it.
>> Marilyn Church: You
know, I don't know how it is
in California and the Midwest
in terms of how many men,
women in New York,
it's practically all
women all the time.
There was Joe Papin, years ago
and there were a few men early
on but they really--
it's women under this--
it always fascinated me why
women ended up being able
to stand that pressure
better than men.
I mean, it's not that they're
better artists or better
under pressure is
all I can think and--
>> Bill Robles: Probably, yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: I believe--
>> Marilyn Church: Is that true
on the coast and in the Midwest?
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church: More
women than men doing this?
>> Pat Lopez: Yes, well,
I was pretty much, I mean,
there were men-- couple of
the men, Gary Myrick, and--
but for-- but I was the
only woman that I know of,
there was a few others who
do it on a local level,
but not on a national level.
I was the only one who did
it on the national level.
And I will add to that
that I agree with you.
I think women on-- in general,
because we raise families
and we do 15,000 other
things while you're changing
that baby's diaper, right--
>> Marilyn Church: That's true.
>> Pat Lopez: -- we
learn to hold so much
in terms of multitasking.
I think that's an issue--
that's probably why--
In fact, I now am a therapist
to counsel in art therapy
with the Jemez tribe
in New Mexico.
And I've learned a great deal
about women of all cultures.
And that's true, multitasking
is women do that so very well.
Maybe that's why.
>> Marilyn Church: Maybe.
I'm sure it's a factor.
>> Bill Robles: Matter of fact,
my other competitor, I guess,
other artists in Los Angeles,
there's basically two of us
and we handle the whole
thing, is a woman, so--
and I've known her for years
but, you know, it's a tough gig.
>> Marilyn Church: It is.
>> Bill Robles: It is, yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Bill Robles: And people
think it's very glamorous
and there is a lot
of glamour to it.
I mean, you see celebrities,
you see important people,
and you're drawn to the--
something you read about all
of a sudden, there
you are-- there--
>> Marilyn Church: Right.
>> Bill Robles: Like these
gentlemen sitting here,
they're that close to you.
It's fascinating.
And that's one of the great
things I love about it.
And you can express your drawing
the way you want to do it.
Nobody is telling
you how to do it.
You do it.
They hire you because
you do it a certain way
and that's what they like.
So, that's the plus side of it.
>> Pat Lopez: But I have-- I had
to struggle to get to that place
where no one would tell
me how to do it, Bill.
I mean, and I don't know why,
maybe it's because
I was a woman.
I could tell you in the Midwest
when I first started out,
I had producer after
producer and news director
after news director saying,
"Well, you need to put him
over here and I need
so and so in there."
But that didn't happen that way.
Yeah. I don't know why.
It took probably
the first 10 years
of my work before I was
honored enough, respect--
my work was respected enough
for no one to art-direct me.
And I don't know if it was
the middle of the nation,
the culture, the community,
I don't know what that was.
But it took a good 10 years
until I could do
whatever I needed to do.
And they would shoot it
no matter what it was.
Was that your experience?
>> Marilyn Church: Well,
I would say it mostly is.
But I'm mostly was able
to accommodate reporters
with what they wanted.
But I-- No, there was
not a lot of direction
from producers or
reporters, some.
That's one of the wonderful
things about this work is
that you are able to have
a lot of self-expression.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church: You
have a lot of control
over how that drawing looks.
And it's doing art in
a place that's live.
It's happening in front of
you with all that drama.
It's a very special
privilege to do this work.
Difficult though, it is.
Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: There's
one other thing.
And I don't know-- I know
that you've had this experience
before, you too, Bill.
The audience around you, there
are times you're there, right,
to do a job and you're doing
your best, but we do make noise,
we do work quickly, we have
our board, we have our paper,
other things around us.
And somebody right behind
me might be very interested
in my work.
So he is leaning over, breathing
down my neck and the person next
to me is very interested
in looking.
Then they start talking to you.
>> Marilyn Chruch: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: Oh, how
did you get out of that?
I mean--
>> Marilyn Church: Oh,
that's a very difficult thing
to deal with.
Also, some of the-- sometimes
the family is sitting there
in the court and objects to
the way you're drawing the.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes, oh.
>> Marilyn Church: It happened
to me at the Gotti trial
where his fellow gang members
are sitting right in the--
here is the artist
row and there is the--
and they coming over
to check the hairline
and the facial expression
and saying, "Hey,
John's got more hair than that."
>> Bill Robles: Oh [laughter].
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
Yeah. I get that a lot.
And I heard it from
Bess Myerson and some
of the women defendants
too would come
and not appreciate the
way you were drawing them.
So, sometimes it
can be intimidating.
>> Pat Lopez: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: Even at
the John Gotti trial actually,
he was in the well of the court
so he couldn't tell me directly
about how he was drawing, but
I saw him as I was drawing
in court and looking at
him through by binoculars,
I see him making a motion,
pointing to his neck,
and he is waving like this at me
and I thought he
couldn't be talking to me.
But I look behind me and the CBS
reporters got their head buried
down and she's not noticing.
And he is saying, he's
motioning yes, you.
And then he points to his
neck and makes a motion
like better not go there because
I was drawing his neck fat
[laughter] and so, I was speedy.
And I knew that John
Gotti was very conscious
of how he was being
covered in the press.
And he was reading all the
news report and he know
which artist was
covering from where.
So, that happens too.
>> Bill Robles: Was
he in custody?
>> Marilyn Church:
He was in custody.
He couldn't come after me.
But all his gang
members could have.
>> Pat Lopez: Well, I did
have a similar situation
that wasn't-- it was in Dallas.
I can't remember the
trial, it's been so long,
that was about skinheads, you
know, the skinhead community.
And they had several
young men there on trial.
And I drew them and
I also drew some
of their family sitting
behind them.
One of them had a wife
and a couple kids.
And I remember going to lunch
that day, and it's weird
that I really got a lunch.
I had to work through
lunch often.
>> Marilyn Church: Yes.
>> Pat Lopez: Put my work
down and went to lunch,
I had 15 minutes, I thought,
well, I'll grab a bite.
As I got into the
elevator to go downstairs,
there were three skinhead
members in the elevator
and you could tell-- oh,
even now it chokes me up,
you can tell they were
very unhappy with me.
And they stood behind me and
made threats, basically said,
I wouldn't make it to my
car that night if I did--
if I put that drawing
on the air.
As soon as the elevator opened,
I stepped back, they got off.
I punch the button, went
back upstairs, and I talked
to the court officer, we
always have a police officer
in the court, and
he took me back
to the judge's chambers
immediately.
I told the judge what happened.
These people weren't
allowed to come back
to the courtroom,
they were arrested.
And for the rest of the trial,
I was escorted out to my car.
So, it can be very
scary at times.
>> Bill Robles: Dangerous
country over there.
>> Pat Lopez: Well, it's Texas.
They're serious in
Texas [laughter].
>> Sara Duke: So,
objectivity is like an issue.
How do you remain objective?
How do you try to
maintain that in your art?
>> Marilyn Church:
That is a challenge.
That's a challenge because
you get emotionally affected
by the testimony.
There were a lot of times
like the terrorism trial,
the World Trade Center
bombing trial, the first one.
That was very hard.
That courtroom was filled
with supporters of, well,
people sympathetic to
some of their defendants.
And it was so distressing,
listening to that testimony
and looking at these defendants
and trying to draw them.
And I'm sure some
of the emotions,
some of the terror I
felt about it got in.
And as a matter of fact, the
artists were sitting in the jury
in that trial, which is--
sometimes we get lucky.
And we can actually see
the faces we're drawing.
But I know my drawing was
in the New York Times,
on the front page
and other artists,
all our drawings
were being shown.
And at one point, the attorney
for one of the defendants came
over to the artists
and the jury and said,
"My client objects the
way you were drawing him.
You're making him look
like a terrorist."
And--
>> Bill Robles: Sorry
about that [laughter].
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah that
was answered but, you know, I--
it was-- again, it's
frightening.
And you do try to think,
I remember also the
Central Park jogger trial,
those four black teens
that were accused
and later found to be innocent.
It was really difficult
because their words,
all their confessions
played for us on the TV
and they were very
surly in court.
They were not schooled in
how to look in a courtroom.
And that's what I drew.
And I know the mothers would
come up to me in the hall
and plead with me, don't
draw my son like that,
you know, he's really innocent.
And years later, when they
were acquitted, I felt very bad
about the way those
drawings did look.
Yeah. But I really do try.
I think we all try to
be objective about it.
Someone's life is on the
line and you want to be fair.
>> Bill Robles: Do you ever
have a defendant that kind
of tries to conceal himself?
>> Marilyn Church: Yes.
>> Bill Robles: Covering the--
>> Pat Lopez: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: Martha
Stewart was very good at that.
She kept pushing her hair down.
The blond hair was--
>> Bill Robles: Sooner or
later, you get them though.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
That's the name of the game.
You always get them
no matter what.
>> Pat Lopez: Well, that's why I
didn't eat lunch a lot of times.
>> Marilyn Church: Yes.
>> Pat Lopez: Because I knew
at some point they'd have
to get up to go to lunch.
And I just sat there until they
moved and then I could see them.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah, if
they stayed in the courtroom.
>> Pat Lopez: If they stayed
in the courtroom, yeah.
There's-- Well, there's things
you can do, as you well know,
to find out where they
are and, you know,
if they're not in the courtroom.
I call the security officers
that are in every federal court,
I call them my donut buddies
for good reason [laughter].
They would always
let me know, yeah,
what would be happening
with the defendant.
And if I needed to see
his face in the hall for--
I just needed a split
second, something--
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: -- anything.
>> Marilyn Church: Yes.
Yeah.
>> Sara Duke: Are there any
questions from the audience?
[ Inaudible ]
>> -- others was in a courtroom
in the US-- oh, thank you.
Did you hear?
>> Sara Duke: Yeah.
So the question is, do any of us
know the first time somebody was
in the courtroom in the US?
Now are you talking about for
television or for newspapers or?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Marilyn Church: Do we
know the first time what?
>> Sara Duke: Somebody worked
in the courtroom in the US.
>> Marilyn Church: Oh,
oh, oh, oh [inaudible].
Yeah, yeah.
What I can remember-- Oh,
I can't-- William Sharp.
It's probably not the first
but I can remember being a very
young child seeing his courtroom
drawings in like magazines and--
>> Bill Robles: Whose?
>> Marilyn Church: William
Sharp, such a good artist.
>> Bill Robles: Doesn't
ring a bell.
>> Marilyn Church: I
wish his work was here.
>> Bill Robles: Courtroom art?
>> Marilyn Church:
Courtroom art, William Sharp.
But it probably goes back to--
well, the way I always
heard it was--
there were artist drawing
before the Lindbergh trial.
And during the Lindbergh trial,
they got evicted because--
>> Bill Robles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: -- they
were making such a commotion.
So who were those artists?
I should know.
I would like to know that.
>> Pat Lopez: I would too.
>> Bill Robles: Well, there
were artists during the
Nuremberg trial--
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Bill Robles: -- in
Germany after World War II,
they were fantastic
illustrators.
And old Sickles was one of them.
[ Inaudible ]
I didn't hear that.
I'm sorry.
>> Sara Duke: He said
that Daumier was the
first courtroom artist.
>> Bill Robles: Oh,
that was in France.
Yeah.
>> Sara Duke: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: But he
wasn't covering as a journalist.
>> Bill Robles: No, right.
>> Marilyn Church: I mean
he was doing his drawings
because he liked to be there.
>> Bill Robles: He
didn't have a deadline.
>> Sara Duke: I mean--
[laughter].
>> Marilyn Church: I like
to be there as an artist.
>> Sara Duke: We happened
to have some sketches
from the Haymarket trial
from the 1880s by--
>> Bill Robles: Oh, yeah?
>> Sara Duke: -- a man named
Art Young who later went
on to become-- who's a
moderate Midwestern conservative
when he drew them and
he drew them guilty
and when he later became a
socialist, he felt baldly
about how he had drawn them.
But we-- At the Library
of Congress,
we don't have a great
selection of kind
of pre-television era drawings
so we didn't include
them in the exhibition.
>> Marilyn Church: But also,
artists like Winslow
Homer did draw--
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church:
-- for newspapers.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church: And I'm sure
if there was a courtroom trial,
they-- maybe not Winslow
Homer, but probably artists--
>> Pat Lopez: They had someone.
>> Marilyn Church: -- at
the time went into court.
>> Sara Duke: Sure.
Right, right, to draw, yeah.
>> Bill Robles: Well,
they had artists
in the Civil War
that were doing--
>> Marilyn Church: That's right.
>> Bill Robles: --
sketches for newspapers.
>> Sara Duke: Right.
>> Marilyn Church: That's true.
>> Marilyn Church: But
that's not courtroom art--
>> Bill Robles: No, right.
>> Marilyn Church:
-- particularly but--
>> Sara Duke: Well, in many
ways, you are the people
who inherited that
tradition of--
>> Marilyn Church: Yes.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Sara Duke: -- reportage.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Bill Robles: So it's
been going on but--
>> Marilyn Church: And we
always wished it was the--
in more than just the courtroom.
You know, as it used to
be, I mean artist were--
>> Sara Duke: Right.
>> Marilyn Church: But this
is the last bastion, right?
>> Sara Duke: I think we have
one more question up here.
>> Well, I find the
discussion fascinating
and your work is
just remarkable.
I was interested in one of the
questions that were posed to you
by the moderator, the
one about objectivity.
First of all, what's the--
is there a duty of
objectivity for your work?
You said that you have
the freedom as an artist.
So where does this requirement
to be objective comes from?
And secondly, you noted
that sometimes you were drawing
characters in the courtroom
and afterwards you were
sorry for way you drew them.
Was there any experience that
you had in which you disagreed
with a judgment made by a judge
that you covered the courtroom?
>> Marilyn Church:
You mean the--
what the jury-- the verdict?
>> Yes.
>> Marilyn Church: Oh, yeah
lots of times [laughter].
Well, actually, not
so many times.
Certainly the O.J.,
but I can't remember.
I don't know.
Do you want to--
>> Bill Robles: Nor can I.
>> Marilyn Church: I mean,
I think it's a very
difficult thing to come
up with a verdict sometimes.
I've struggled myself,
what would I do,
you know, in this case.
Well, how would I vote?
It's really hard.
And we also hear a lot
more that the jury does.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church: We see
stuff that can't go into trial.
>> Bill Robles: Oh, absolutely.
>> Marilyn Church: And
we know background,
we know other charges that
the jury doesn't know.
So, I can't think of a better
system that's everybody says,
right, than what we have but--
[ Inaudible ]
>> Bill Robles: I
didn't quite hear it.
>> Sara Duke: Do you have
an ethical requirement
to be objective?
Is there a requirement to
be objective in your work?
>> Pat Lopez: May I?
>> Marilyn Church: Sure.
>> Pat Lopez: I don't understand
how you can ask an artist,
any artist to be objective.
This is art even though we do
our best to be fair, right?
I don't know any other--
but I think objective is the
wrong term because I'm not sure
that I could be objective
drawing anyone of you right now.
You know what I'm saying?
This is what I feel.
What I see is what I see.
You may see something different.
She would do a completely
different drawing than I would
if we were drawing
the same person.
I don't know.
Does that make any sense?
>> Marilyn Church: Absolutely.
But I always have it in mind
too that you are a reporter too.
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
Yes, that too.
>> Marilyn Church: And not
to be inaccurate about--
>> Pat Lopez: Right.
>> Marilyn Church:
-- what's going on.
Not to make somebody angrier
than what was happening--
>> Pat Lopez: That's true.
>> Marilyn Church: -- or--
>> Marilyn Church: --
more hysterical than
what was happening.
Although news reporters tend
to want to push that angle--
>> Pat Lopez: Yes.
>> Marilyn Church:
-- so you are.
>> Pat Lopez: But I
think that's different.
Being--
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: --
accurate is different
than being objective, right?
>> Marilyn Church:
No, I agree with you.
You have to let the
emotions feel you.
>> Pat Lopez: Absolutely.
>> Marilyn Church: I think that
makes a good courtroom drawing,
actually, that you are
present and listening
and feeling what's
going on and that's--
those feelings do
get in the drawing.
Yeah? I think so.
>> Bill Robles: Microphone.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Actually.
This actually was kind
of on the same subject.
It was really [inaudible]
already.
But how do you especially in a
very viscerally disturbing trial
that goes on for weeks.
How do you manage absorbing that
emotion day after day and trying
to still do the rest
of your life
and walk back in
and do it again?
I realize you're
all professionals,
but how do you mediate that?
>> Pat Lopez: That maybe why I
became a therapist [laughter].
>> Marilyn Church: It's true.
I've had nightmares about some
other trials listening too.
Sometimes it parallels
things in your own life.
You know, your son may be the
same age is the defendant and,
you know, it can really-- you
do have to distance yourself.
>> Bill Robles: Absolutely.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
Its--
>> Bill Robles: We hear a lot
of gory stuff I'll tell you.
>> Marilyn Church: Yup.
>> Bill Robles: Terrible
stuff but you have
to put it behind you--
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Bill Robles: -- and
not let it affect you.
>> Pat Lopez: It-- However,
I know you can't really
put some things behind you.
It does affect you--
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: -- when you're
sitting in that courtroom.
In my case in the Oklahoma City
bombing case there were friends
of my family who had
died in the bombing
and their family was behind
me and that was difficult.
But I had to maintain a very--
I had put up my walls
and maintain a very focused
stance and do my work.
>> Marilyn Church: Yup.
>> Pat Lopez: Then it
wasn't until after that case
that I did seek my own
therapy for a little while
to release, because you have to.
You can't hold on to this.
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Sara Duke: We have
one more question.
>> You're all classically
trained artists.
So you're sketching with ink,
you're sketching with pencil,
you're sketching with whatever.
How has technology
changed the way
that courtroom artists has done?
I realize that everybody that
has an iPad can take a photo
and there may be issues there.
But in general,
how is technology changing
things one way or the other?
>> Bill Robles: Are you
talking about how it affects us?
>> Courtroom artists.
>> Bill Robles: Oh, we still do
what we do but I've noticed--
I mean, since I started,
everybody
and their brothers had
a laptop, you know.
Every-- I was at
the Robert Durst,
the New York millionaire
that's accused
of killing his wife
in Los Angeles.
They have a pretrial
thing going on.
And everybody in the
audience, all the media,
they all had laptops and
all the lawyers had laptops
and they walk around
the court with laptops.
And here we're still doing--
>> Marilyn Church: Yeah.
>> Bill Robles: -- what we do.
And which is wonderful.
>> Bill Robles: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: Cameras for
the most part are not allowed
at least on the federal
level into courtrooms
which is the only
reason we have a job, so.
>> Bill Robles: Well, a lot of
lawyers don't want the camera
in high-profile trials.
>> Marilyn Church: Right.
But there's some that do.
>> Bill Robles: Some do.
OK.
>> Marilyn Church: But so far,
the judges have ruled
against it.
>> Pat Lopez: I think it's--
This is a true art form.
It's none-- like nothing
that I learned in college
but this is a true art
form, to be able to do this
in a limited amount of time
and try to remain as true
and accurate as you can
to the scene or the story.
So I don't want to see it die,
but I know that the
media is changing
because of the technology.
They don't cover trials
like they used to.
And I wish they'd go back to it.
Anybody listening?
>> Marilyn Church: One way it's
changed though is artists take
their own photographs after the
trail, which didn't use to be.
>> Bill Robles: Really, yeah.
>> Pat Lopez: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: They used
to have a crew out there.
>> Bill Robles: I
forgot about that.
>> Pat Lopez: Yeah.
>> Marilyn Church: And it's
added another layer to our work.
You know, its not only that
you have to do all the art,
you also got to take the
photograph and get it back
to the station or the
newspaper on time.
>> Bill Robles: I did that
last Tuesday with the Durst.
I had-- They didn't have a
camera crew or reporter there
so I had to shoot the drawing--
>> Marilyn Church:
So you were it.
>> Bill Robles: --
and ship it back.
You know, it's more work.
>> Marilyn Church: And sometimes
they even ask you what happened.
They do. They do sometimes.
If there was no reporter
there, and so--
>> Sara Duke: Oh, I think
we've run out of time.
So I want to--
>> Bill Robles: One
more question I think.
>> Sara Duke: No, I think
we've run out of time.
>> Bill Robles: Oh,
OK [laughter].
>> Sara Duke: Cut it off
from the back of the room.
I want you to all join me
in thanking Bill
and Marilyn and Pat.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.